sí
para alcanzar los objetivos de diseño
que nos pide el departamento de
historias también necesitamos cambiar el
tamaño de los objetos de nuestra escena
por ejemplo puedo meter la voz en la
toma pero claramente no es del tamaño
indicado en el boceto podemos cambiar el
tamaño de voz haciéndolo por ejemplo del
doble del tamaño usando la operación de
modificación de escalas para modificar
la escala de un objeto al doble de su
tamaño original
tengo que multiplicar las coordenadas de
cada uno de sus puntos por un factor de
2 como sucedía antes con la traslación
puedo escoger cualquier punto inicial y
llamémosle a sus coordenadas x cero ig-0
después de escalarlo se convierte en el
punto x uno de uno y esta fórmula de
aquí muestra como las coordenadas de
cada punto se están multiplicando por
dos
para hacer que algo sea ese veces más
grande tenemos que multiplicar por s si
éste es mayor que 1 las cosas se vuelven
más grandes y si s es menor que 1 pero
sigue siendo positivo las cosas se hacen
más pequeñas podemos resumir todo esto
diciendo que las matemáticas de la
modificación de escalas son la
multiplicación por otro lado si el
factor de escala de x es mayor que el de
y estoy estirando horizontalmente al
objeto y ahora tú piensa en qué es lo
que pasaría si el factor de iu es más
grande que el de x y también piensa en
qué pasaría si ese fuera negativo
generalmente necesitamos hacer ambas
cosas trasladar y escalar a los objetos
para colocarlos donde queremos
yo ya modifique la escala de la pelota
luxo así es que ya podemos colocarla
usando la traslación y otra vez
hago clic en la posición inicial puedes
ver a dónde se va el punto después de
las dos operaciones aquí las fórmulas
nos dicen que se están realizando dos
operaciones en el próximo ejercicio tu
tarea es mejorar la toma del último
ejercicio agregando objetos que
requieren traslación y cambio de escala
pero recuerda si requieren rotación no
debes colocarlos en la toma todavía tú
hazlo con calma tómate tu tiempo aunque
el departamento de animación ha estado
esperando esta toma desde hace como dos
semanas así es que mejor nos vemos como
en 10 minutos